E aí
[Música]
o Olá Todos eu devo dizer que o João já
disse muita coisa Ok e se calhar não vou
precisar de morar os 12 minutos
eu gostava primeiro de conversar que
quando recebi o telefonema com um
convite para estar aqui o meu primeiro
pensamento foi o que é que será que eles
querem que eu falo porque podia ser o
trabalho científico faço na universidade
podia ser o porquê é que uma cientista
escreve histórias para criança nos
tempos livres ou ainda porque é que a
cientista aos 48 anos acha que ainda é
possível o time ainda em ser Bailarina e
eu fiquei muito contente de ser a
primeira hipótese porque porque quem
trabalha em ciência e em particular
nesta área de protecção do ambiente a
oportunidade estar aqui a falar sobre o
problema neste caso da qualidade do ar
que os vou falar no poder estar ensinar
algumas coisas de falar em meio caminho
andado para resolver o problema Por isso
só para te explicar que é com todo o que
aceitei o convite estou aqui mas como
gosto muito de contar histórias a
história que eu vos trago hoje aqui
começa assim ou o init isso é
e esta e a resposta a isto seu Ok esta é
isso é muito fácil de perceber ou o
porquê é que eu digo isto se vocês se
compararmos a nossa sobrevivência
relativamente aos principais recursos
que nós precisamos o ar a água EA comida
facilmente vocês percebem que aqui umas
uma dependência Total deste recurso
solar
é só que não basta que o ar tirar estar
tem que ter tem que ter qualidade caso
contrário a nossa sobrevivência e também
pode continuar comprometida porque
afinal de contas os poluentes do ar tem
efeitos no nossa saúde como vocês já
devem saber e esses efeitos
não são só ao nível do sistema
respiratório como uma primeira
pensamento nós poderíamos achar e o fato
do sistema respiratório é o primeiro a
ser afetado Só que os poluentes depois
acabam por passar para a Corrente
sanguínea E aí vamos ter efeitos ao
nível do sistema cardiovascular também e
eu acho que esta complexidade de
defeitos e também a questão dos clientes
que tornam este problema da poluição do
ar mais difícil de ser avaliado
diagnosticado percebido porque afinal de
contas os poluentes não tem cor a maior
parte não tem cheiro
a curto EA longo prazo e é difícil por
tudo isto é difícil perceber a dimensão
deste problema
felizmente recentemente a Organização
Mundial de Saúde começou a alertar para
este problema e identificou com uma
grande ameaça ambiental da atualidade
para a nossa saúde humana e começou a
lançar números cá para fora um deles por
exemplo foi este e este número mesmo que
ele tivesse colocado Pequenino eu sei
que as pétalas gostam destes nomes
gregos Mas mesmo que ele tivesse por
Pequenino ele ia ele ia dizer
impressionar de certeza porque porque
ele significa o número de mortes
prematuras de vida a poluição
atmosférica no nosso mundo em cada ano
Oi e a questão é mais crítica por quê
Porque este risco da poluição
atmosférica é comparável aos maiores
riscos que nós temos também para a saúde
não sente só questão ambiental por
exemplo alguns ossos conhecem bem o
alcoolismo tabagismo
obesidade os acidentes rodoviários EA
poluição do ar sempre pedisse para
ordenar por risco eu experimentei em
casa e não é fácil digo já dá acertar
mas vamos ver como é que é o resultado
da ordenação
Oi e a poluição atmosférica vem em
quarto lugar antes dos acidentes
rodoviários e os acidentes rodoviários
estão presentes na nossa cabeça muito no
nosso dia-a-dia sobretudo quando andamos
de carro certo só que agora Vocês
perguntam e com toda a lógica Então mas
afinal de contas como é que é a
qualidade do ar que nós respiramos aqui
em Portugal aqui em Aveiro ela não é
pior existem sítios Onde esta Além Deste
problema é muito mais grave muito mais
sério também não é melhor já foi pior
mas tem que ser melhor ainda e eu
acredito que isso não ajudou muito Não
clarificou muito mas talvez com este
gráfico seja possível estes dois
gráficos mostram as tendências que
ocorreram em Portugal em vários número
de dias que é que estudemos o valor
limite de proteção para a saúde humana
destes dois poluentes as partículas e os
óxidos de azoto
a e agora Vocês perguntam também que eu
imagina então eu CO2 não está aqui e eu
estou a perguntar isto porque quando
falo de qualidade do ar é divulgar o
primeiro poluente que aparece na cabeça
ser o CO2 o CO2 é um gás com efeito
estufa e é responsável o maior
responsável pelas alterações climáticas
mas não os afeta a saúde diretamente ou
seja por exemplo deste evento até que
estivesse a ser como normalmente numa no
centro de congressos numa Sala fechada
cheia de gente no final os níveis de CO2
e um ser elevadíssimos mas a nossa saúde
não ia estar comprometida isto se
tivermos o oxigênio suficiente para
respirar eu acredito que organização
interna eu iria facilitar isso OK mas
isso só para explicar que não é do CO2
que eu estou aqui a falar mas sim destes
poluentes que se calhar para vocês tem o
nome um bocadinho esquisito e como vocês
briga que estão em Portugal não é e não
é muito a tenista mas nós em vez de
compararmos com a legislação formos
comparar com as linhas orientadoras da
Organização Mundial de Saúde o cenário é
muito mais vermelho porque porque estas
linhas estão muito mais exigentes Ok
porque a Organização Mundial de Saúde
acha que a partir de um certo nível já
efeitos na saúde enquanto que o nível
caiu na legislação é mais baixo Ok um
aspecto positivo a legislação está a ser
revista e quer ir ao encontro das
recomendações da OMS
só que o ms também está a rever e também
vai ser mais exigente no futuro ou seja
senhores não fizermos nada este cenário
vai continuar e vai ser mais grave ainda
mais vermelho ainda porque os níveis vão
ser mais exigentes e
eu e o meu capítulo 2 da história diz o
limite Esse é o que é que será que eu
quero dizer com isso será que é bom ou
mau
e na verdade nós podemos
classificar em quatro grandes fontes e
as responsáveis por aquelas
concentrações que eu há bocado referi
naqueles influentes críticos nas áreas
urbanas quatro fontes diferentes os
transportes EA que eu estou a falar
transporte rodoviário e não rodoviário o
aquecimento doméstico a indústria EA
produção de energia e o tratamento de
resíduos Estas são digamos as quatro
principais fontes que podemos dizer
responsáveis pela poluição em áreas
urbanas e se vocês repararem duas delas
estão diretamente relacionadas com as
nossas atividades e com as nossas
escolhas do dia a dia quando pegamos um
carro quando escolhemos o tipo de
aquecimento em casa
e a pandemia ou melhor confinamento vem
nos mostrar isso vamos confirmar aquilo
que nós na ciência já sabemos Mas é
engraçado que tivemos as canções deste
ano esta estação que existe na Avenida
da Liberdade em Lisboa
desde que foi colocada lá em 2005 nunca
foi possível de cumprir o valor anual do
limite de proteção da Saúde Humana
relativamente a este poluente que é
totalmente ligado ao tráfico e tráfico é
o grande responsável por este presente
nunca foi possível até 2020 foi o
primeiro ano em que isto foi possível
eu não quero com isto dizer que nós
vamos ter que ficar confinados para o
resto da vida para resolver o problema
da qualidade do ar não não é isso de
todo mas temos que tirar lições daqui e
definitivamente mudar a mobilidade
urbana as nossas escolhas e estratégia
política é a solução a solução passa
definitivamente por aqui
Ah e por isso é que eu acabo essa
história e porque eu acho que lá no
fundo todos nós gostamos das histórias
que acabam bem sobretudo as de amor e
este Love que eu digo aqui e e não não
vai a pressão não tem que por a música
dos Beatles não tá combinado Ok
este lado no fundo resumo de uma forma
bonita e resumida a mensagem que eu fiz
queria trazer aqui less Open Fire
veículo emissions as duas grandes áreas
onde nós podemos fazer algo no caso dos
transportes por exemplo e olha a cidade
de Aveiro conhecida como a Veneza de
Portugal podia também ser amsterdão de
Portugal e na se tentou com a cidade das
burgas mas ele definitivamente vocês
procurarem por eles não é assim tão
fácil de encontrar e sabem porque
e eu acho que sabes contar esta história
se calhar responde um bocadinho esta
questão eu comprei meu primeiro carro
aos 30 anos já tinha 30 anos já
trabalhava há alguns anos e os meus
vizinhos vieram dar os parabéns acabou o
curso parabéns carro novo eu acho que
explica
muito porque tenho ver estamos a ver
estes carros todos não estamos a ver em
bicicletas em vez porque haverá uma
cidade perfeita para isso é plana é
pequena e eu digo isso por experiência
própria que depois entretanto comprei um
carro e fiz e faço viagens de cá tem
muitos casos não sei se até a maioria de
carro eu demorei mais tempo do que se
fosse de bicicleta em Aveiro porque eu
estou a dizer isto porque nem sempre por
exemplo a bicicleta é alternativa é mas
há outras alternativas quando é
bicicleta por exemplo não é o quando a
outras boleia ou com o nome muito
pomposo cardsharing outra forma de abrir
mais mas eu só tenho 12 minutos está bem
e ainda vez quero falar das lareiras
também não quero com isto dizer que não
usei não aceitam vossa lareira Não não é
isso a minha filha de 8 anos já sabe
muito bem os dias em que não há problema
nenhum de acender a lareira lá em casa
quando chove ou quando faz vento não
vamos ter problemas de dispersão de
poluentes e não vamos ter episódios de
partículas no dia a seguir é só um
exemplo OK e eu para acabar a história
ainda de uma forma mais bonita essa
história essa história pode ter não Um
final feliz' mas dois também porque
porque isso que eu estou a falar destas
duas formas de atuação vai ter também
repercussão ao nível do CO2 o tal gás
com efeito estufa responsável e
climáticas ou seja se nós atuarmos não
vamos estar só a melhorar a qualidade do
ar que nós respiramos mas estamos a
melhorar as alterações climáticas que um
problema a nível global e eu escolhi
esta imagem que há muitas imagens
incríveis que ilustram bem a questão das
alterações climáticas porque é de uma
ilustradora a famosa já ao nível mundial
já muito reconhecida e que nasceu o
mesmo lhe e quem sabe no próximo teto x
ela não poderá estar aqui muito obrigada
a todos
E aí